- Sheep, sheep, sheep!
Hi, guys.
Hi, Bubbles.
Hi, Walter.
Hi, Dolly.
Hey, momma.
Hi, baby.
Hi, Alvie.
(sheep bellowing)
- One, two, three.
- Janie's farm didn't
start out with animals
that were missing limbs.
It just happened to come to her farm
and she felt, well, prothetic
technology's helped me,
it could certainly help them.
(rooster crowing)
(celebratory music)
- I can't imagine not having
not having an artificial leg
because I lost my leg at 10
and I'm quite used to it.
It's thanks to medical
science that I'm able to
live this normal life.
And for these animals,
I want no different for them.
Hi, Felix.
What goes on at Woodstock Farm
Sanctuary on a daily basis
we're home to right now around
300 rescued farm animals.
They've all come from bad places
and they get the veterinary care,
the healthcare that they
need on a daily basis.
(cow mooing)
- [Man] Hi, Precious.
(laughing)
- [Man] What's the matter with you?
- [Man] No, she's feisty.
- Can you come help me with Felix?
They're all actually in the front pasture.
Little Felix came to us a baby lamb
and he had come from a big sheep farm.
And overnight, some sort
of predator had gotten in
and they found little Felix with
his leg chewed off.
And so, I spoke to my prosthetist,
the gentleman who makes my legs, Eric.
- Ah, I don't if many clinicians
would have went out to the farm.
I don't have any experience
with fitting prosthetics on animals.
Very few people in the country do.
So, I figured if I could take
what knowledge that I do have
and apply it to the animal
I could probably get them
to utilize a prosthesis.
- And it wasn't until we
got hooked up SUNY New Paltz
and their 3-D printing lab
that we were able to make
something pretty cool
and cutting edge for him.
- Seeing him walk on the
leg was absolutely amazing.
From my limited interactions with him,
he isn't necessarily the most
outgoing sheep in the world.
He's actually very sheepish.
But, what he ended up doing was
he started running away
from us which was amazing.
- We were just jumping for
joy that he could actually
get up and run,
keep up with his flock.
He looked like he was a very happy sheep.
If we could do this more on other animals
we wouldn’t, you know, have to put them down.
- Most of the world doesn't
fully understand it.
They think of them as just farmed animals,
but we hope that that changes.
And that's part of the
magic of what we do here.
They get pastures to roam in,
access to the sun and to the grass.
They live life the way
they were intended to live.
There's no greater joy.